12 janvier 1934 les premières lueurs du
jour dévoile une masse sombre s'échouant
sur la plage de galets de fond
bourrelets à case-pilote il s'agit du
corps sans vie d'un homme ligoté et
manifestement torturé un homme qui a
payé de sa vie le combat qu'il menait
contre l'injustice en martinique
andré aliker avait 40 ans c'est sa mère
louise anne aliker dit fanfan qui lui
aurait transmis son tempérament de feu
[Musique]
monsieur vos conduits là installée dans
le bourg buts et d'esprit vous vous
imaginer à l'époque il a vécu avec cette
négresse analphabètes et qui a eu ce
qu'elle lui se battre aussi bien contre
la communauté blanche et qui n'a pas
admis que les objectifs avec une
négresse face sept enfants avec elles
vivent avec elle cet esprit elhadj
battre aussi contre l'ignoble esprit qui
eux aussi la regarder de façon spéciale
donc je crois que ce combat dès le
départ qu'elle adule menée et elle a
inculqué ces principes là ses enfants un
courage remarquer jusque dans les
tranchées de la première guerre mondiale
engagé dans les troupes françaises sa
hiérarchie soulignera qu'il est toujours
volontaire pour les missions les plus
périlleuses
de retour en martinique il monte un
petit commerce et se passionne pour le
journalisme il devient rédacteur en chef
du journal justice l'organe de presse du
parti communiste martiniquais dans
lequel il publie les articles au vitriol
toujours très court et efficace dans les
années 30 la martinique est un vaste
champ de canne à sucre que se partagent
une dizaine de grandes familles békés à
la faveur d'un bon mariage avec une
héritière ayotte eugène au berry est
devenu la figure la plus puissante de
lille aliker apprend qu'il est au coeur
d'un vaste scandale financier mêlant
fraude fiscale et corruption de
magistrat il publie à la une sans
hésiter et preuves à l'appui la
simulation commence de l'argent on lui a
proposé d'avoir dérobé est plus
important d'aller ouvrir des capitaux à
des crédits à la banque ont fait ya
plein de choses qu'on ne lui a pas fait
qu'on ne lui a pas proposé il a toujours
refusé en disant qu'il ne pourrait pas
se regarder dans un miroir comme par
hasard la banque le couple que du bon
l'imprimé qui publie justice avait
refusé de publier le journal
enfin une coopérative en relais et
jusqu'à des menaces physiques le 3
novembre 1933 aliker l'incorruptible est
ainsi passé à tabac en sortant du cirque
avec ses enfants sur la place de lass
abad
deux mois plus tard il enlevait ligoté
et jeté à la mer à fort de france il
s'en sort grâce à ses talents de nageurs
avant de prévenir ses proches
sheila qu'il écrit à son frère pierre
aliker qui était étudiant en médecine
que et pense que au berry a mis sa tête
à prix
le board armes qu'ils réclament pour se
protéger lui est refusé et quelques
jours plus tard la seconde tentative
d'assassinât est la bonne
on est venu le chercher à son magasin
sur le bord de mer et il a suivi des
notamment un ami qui l'avait qui le
connaissaient nos qui lui avait dit qu
corrompu et il l'a suivi sans hésiter
c'est là qu'il a été agressé et là le
lendemain la nouvelle de la mort d'ali
caire se répand l'émotion est immense
son frère marcel tente de le venger et
tire sur aube et rythmé son arme
s'enraye
devant la pression populaire il sera
acquitté par le tribunal
la population a plus ratés comme ce pas
pour lui il est porteur un triomphe est
allé photo qui la montre est bon voilà
le procès aliker a lieu à bordeaux en
janvier 1936 deux assassins présumés
sont relaxés faute de preuves tandis
qu'eugène aubéry ne se présente pas et
écope de 100 francs d'amendé
mais la légende andré aliker est déjà en
marche
[Musique]